in the dialectic of sense certainty
seeing and hearing have been lost to
consciousness
and as perception consciousness has
arrived at thoughts which it brings
together for the first time in the
unconditioned universal
this now if it were taken as an inert
simple essence would itself be in turn
nothing else in the one-sided extreme
of being for self for it would then be
confronted by
non-essence but if it were related to
this
it would itself be unessential and
consciousness would not have escaped
from the deceptions
of the perceptual process however this
universal has proved to be one which is
returned
into itself out of such a condition
being for self
this unconditioned universal which is
now the true object of consciousness
is still just an object for it
consciousness has not yet grasped the
notion of the unconditioned
as notion it is essential to distinguish
the two
for consciousness the object has
returned into itself from its relation
to another
and has thus become notion in principle
but consciousness
is not yet for itself the notion
and consequently does not recognize
itself in that reflected
object for us this object has developed
through the movement of consciousness in
such a way that consciousness
is involved in that development and the
reflection is the same
on both sides or there is only one
reflection
but since in this movement consciousness
has for its content
merely the objective essence and not
consciousness as such
the result must have an objective
significance for consciousness
consciousness still shrinks away from
what has emerged
and takes it as the essence in the
objective sense
we have now made it past the first two
sections of
consciousness since certainty and
perception and we saw that both of them
while they involved some sort of
progress also arrived
at an impasse and it's best to think of
us
especially as we go forward with this
work as
not simply having a section here and a
section there and a section there
and treating something you know
independently of everything else
some of the same dialectical movements
that you're going to see happening in
sense certainty or in perception or
enforcing the understanding
are going to be repeated later on down
the line but we should think of them as
sort of
ascending as sense perception or sense
certainty played itself out here we
arrived at the point of having the
universal
then we took that into perception and we
thought about this universal and we we
turned our attention back
to the thing and how does the thing work
we arrive at you know what hegel is
calling the sophistry of common sense
thinking
or of the understanding at the end of
perception
and now we're moving into a different
section
force and the understanding a longer
section
and in many respects deeper more
involved but also
sort of raising things up to a higher
level
i've expressed this in part by talking
here about
epistemology leading into metaphysics
this is a section which has a lot of
metaphysics
going on and it's very murky it's
actually quite daunting to jump into it
but we're gonna just plow straight ahead
and
see how far we can get so hegel
is now going to bring in this term the
unconditioned
universal and
what does he mean by that the unbedented
alga mine height
we've had universals up to this point
but what we've realized
is that each one of these universals was
actually
conditioned it was a sensuous universal
so the whiteness of the chalk or the the
salt would be an example of such a
universal chalk as
such would be another such universal
now we're looking at something that is
as he says
unconditioned it has a
wider scope as a matter of fact even to
speak of it as
having a wider scope is probably a
little misleading
because when we're saying it's
unconditioned it doesn't have any
restrictions upon it so what could we be
talking about there that's why we're
doing metaphysics we are
now investigating something
that falls within the category of being
as as such so he says um
in sense certainty hearing and seeing
have been lost to consciousness we've
left those behind
per as perception consciousness arrived
at thoughts
which it brings together for the first
time in the unconditioned universal
all those those things that were being
diffused off in this direction or that
direction
are now part of the unconditioned
universal
this now if it were taken as an inert
simple essence he says would itself be
in turn nothing than the one-sided
extreme of being for
self for then it would have to be
confronted by non-essence but we don't
want to do
that same dialectical dance once again
instead we want this to be
a resting point it won't turn out to be
uh of course it never does
angle doesn't until we get to the end of
the book but
um we want to try to avoid falling into
some of the same
uh cul-de-sacs that we were in before
so he says if it were related to this
non-essence it would be itself
unessential consciousness would not have
escaped from the deceptions of the
perceptual process we saw this worked
out
previously in section 130 and 131 didn't
we
so we we don't want to go back to that
we want to do something new here he says
this universal has proved to be one
which is returned to itself out of such
a conditioned
being for self i don't write the being
for self appearing you'll see why
in just just a moment so he says
this unconditioned universal which is
now the true object
of consciousness okay so we've got this
as being the object of consciousness the
unconditioned universal
right that's what consciousness
is really grasping consciousness thought
that it was grasping
all these sensuous particulars before
even thought it was grasping other
universals
and now it's trying to make sense out of
universality as such it's trying to say
what
what is going on here what am i actually
perceiving
here's where hegel is going to uh you
know introduce one of his bifurcations a
doubling
he says so it's unconditioned universal
is is an
object for consciousness consciousness
has not yet grasped
something that's going to be correlative
to it
the notion the grip
the concept the living unity the dynamic
unity of the unconditioned universal so
consciousness is grasping it
as he's going to say in an objective
fashion
and here objective is actually
in a certain way in an impoverished
fashion it's not
grasping the unconditioned universal
as the notion now he's going to
introduce another
distinction here as well that we want to
pay attention to
he says it's essential to distinguish
between
the object
that's returned into itself from its
relation to another and thus has become
a notion
in principle so we have an object that
is a
notion in let's call it in
theory right
and then we have the notion
which requires that consciousness
become for itself a notion
what does all this mean is this a purely
nominal distinction
as we might say we don't what what's the
difference between grasping something
objectively
and grasping something in terms of its
notion
you know in one sense you can grasp its
notion objectively
what is that thing
in another sense this is where hegel is
getting at
the role of consciousness you're only
grasping it
as a notion if you also are
realizing that the very consciousness by
which
you who are consciousness is
making sense of this is also a notion
and that those two notions
subject and object are in some way being
interconnected with each other in ways
that are not quite yet clear
but this much at least is clear for
hegel that that
we have to see that consciousness is in
fact itself
a notion so he says it doesn't reflect
it doesn't recognize itself in the
reflected object it thinks that the
object is something separate from it
for us the object is developed through
the movement of consciousness in such a
way that consciousness
is involved in that development this is
something that has been stressed
and has been brought home to us over and
over and over again
consciousness as it's being conscious of
something
is involved as an activity in
making sense of that the unraveling of
these dialectical threads
has been an activity of consciousness so
he says
there is only one reflection but since
in this movement consciousness has for
its content
merely the objective essence and not
consciousness as such that is
consciousness is looking at
this thematically it's doing a
metaphysics of the
object but it's not yet grasping
itself reflexively doing a
metaphysics of the subject because it's
doing that he says
the result must have an objective
significance for consciousness
consciousness still shrinks away
from what has emerged and takes it as
the essence in the objective sense
not yet in its full conceptual sense
with this the understanding has indeed
superseded its own untruth and the
untruth of the object
what is emerged for it as a result is
the notion of the true
but only as the implicit being of the
true
which is not yet notion or which lacks
the being for
self of consciousness and which the
understanding
without knowing itself therein lets go
its own way
this truth follows out its own essence
so that consciousness
plays no part in its free realization
but merely looks on and simply
apprehends it
to begin with therefore we must step
into its place and be the notion which
develops and fills out
what is contained in the result it is
through awareness of this completely
developed
object which presents itself to
consciousness as something that
immediately
is that consciousness first becomes
explicitly a consciousness that
comprehends
its object
here in section 133 hegel is
playing this out a little bit more and
we're going to see
an interesting shift from the
understanding to consciousness
and then to this we that i put a
question mark next to for reasons you'll
see in just a minute now he begins this
by saying
that what's going on here so this is
going back to what happened in
perception is that the understanding
and its object are now related to each
other in a certain way
the understanding has come to understand
that it contains a certain measure of
untruth right we talked about this in
terms of deception
but it's also come to grasp that the
object itself contains a certain
untruth that it's not fully what it
pretended to be or rather didn't pretend
to be but understanding took it as
uh at the beginning as the object was
unraveled into things like the also and
the one
you know the the chiasm of being
for self and being for another all those
sorts of things
it's untruth it's it the fact that it is
not
entirely what it was to be was revealed
in it
and this has the product
for the understanding of leading us to
the concept of the true as
he says so let's let's see he says um
we we what has emerged for it as a
result is the notion of the true
but now this is only the implicit notion
of the true it's not
fully the notion of true we just saw in
the previous passage what makes it
fully the notion well consciousness has
to be involved
so now we have a shift from
just understanding what you might say is
part of consciousness or a mode of
consciousness but not the totality of it
we have a shift from understanding to
consciousness per se
and consciousness now looks on
the truth it tries to grasp the
notion of it but as we saw in the last
section it does so in an objective
manner which means that in this case it
just looks on then
don't confuse this by the way with
sometimes uh
you know they'll translate on xiaomi as
um
looking on but that can also be
translated as intuition this is just
zeus
just looking it apprehends it
it it grasps it it takes it in
but it takes it in as something other
than itself although it has
consciousness of the object and
also has consciousness of the true or
truth it hasn't yet made it entirely its
own
in part because it's taking this rather
passive
attitude towards it so hegel says um
what happens in this case is the
understanding doesn't know itself
in what's happening and it lets the
truth just kind of go its own way
consciousness just watches this happen
consciousness doesn't intervene and say
hey understanding
get it together or it doesn't say that
to itself either
so he says the truth follows out its own
essence consciousness plays no part in
its free
realization the question is what about
this over here this
free realization
you see truth for hegel isn't just
a matter of noting the correspondence
between say things in language or things
and and thought
it's rather you know seeing the truth as
it develops
as it actualizes itself as it engages in
activity as it unfolds
so what can we do here
here's where hegel is going to bring in
the we
and he says something really interesting
here
he talks about this we as doing several
different things
one is that the we
inserts itself into the
place the stella of consciousness it's
it's
slot you might say and so he says
we must step into its place and be
its notion which develops and fills out
what is contained in the result
so the we is consciousness that is
conscious
of being
the notion it is not merely conscious of
the notion
as an object it is conscious of being
the notion so
what does this get us he says be the
notion which develops and fills out what
is contained in the result
it's through awareness of this
completely developed object
which presents itself to consciousness
is something that immediately is that's
a you know key word right there
immediately is
that consciousness first becomes
explicitly
a consciousness that comprehends its
object so
consciousness is being conscious of the
very
fact that it grasps the truth
and that it grasps the object
through the understanding this is
consciousness now taking stock of itself
the result was the unconditioned
universal
initially in the negative and abstract
sense that
consciousness negated its one-sided
notions and abstracted them
in other words it gave them up but the
result
has implicitly a positive significance
in it the unity of being for self
and being for another is posited in
other words the absolute antithesis
is posited as a self-identical essence
at first sight this seems to concern
only the form of the moments in
reciprocal relation
but being for self and being for another
are the content
itself as well since the antithesis in
its truth can have no other nature than
the one yielded in the result
that is that the content taken in
perception to be true belongs in fact
only to the form in the unity of which
it is dissolved
this content is likewise universal there
can be no other content which by its
particular constitution
would fail to fall within this
unconditioned universality
a content of this kind would be some
particular way
or other of being for itself and a being
in relation to
another but in general to be for itself
and to be in relation to another
constitutes the nature and essence of
the content
whose truth consists in its being
unconditionally universal
and the result is simply and solely
universal
section 134 is going to introduce a new
distinction
that hegel is going to play off of quite
a lot
throughout this this entire section
force and the understanding
that between content in halt in german
and form just form and
you know we these are correlatives right
when we think about
um you know something having a
particular form we're thinking about
something in a general way or a
universal way
and then it can be filled out by
particular content or you could even
just think of
forms that you have to fill in on online
you know for example or by hand
with content you put in whatever content
you like
and in a certain sense
the form is what's really most important
to us isn't it
that everything has to be structured in
a particular way
what what content you want to put in
there well that's just up to you
that's that's the particularity that's
the arbitrariness of it
so you go to get your driver's license
you fill out a form and they give you
back a form that is your driver's
license and it shows your picture that's
the content for that
and your date of birth and all those
other sorts of things
now we can have some sort of general
idea like that in mind but hegel is
going to play around with this in this
section
and we're going to see that things can
be both content and form at the same
time and there's a lot more content
that we we wanted uh then there's a lot
more content than we thought
uh given what we wanted now you notice
he's also bringing up these
old distinctions from the
previous sections being for self
and being for other you remember that
chiastic structure that we talked about
and the fact that these are different
from each other there's in fact an
absolute antithesis between them they're
like polarities you might say
but at the same time one thing is only
a being for self insofar as it is
a being for another and likewise it is
only a being for another in so far as it
is
a being for self and so far as it has a
relation to itself so this also allows
them to say
that there is a posited unity there a
unity
that we have realized and we're sort of
placing
out there notice i don't have
consciousness in this at all that's
going to come up in the next section
so at the same time these two things
exist in an absolute antithesis
to each other they couldn't be more
opposed and yet
they are expressions of a self-identical
essence there's a unity connecting those
two
together and we can even say hey wait a
second
these are even opposed to each other
aren't they
so we have opposition in several
different ways we have opposition about
whether there's opposition going on
we have opposition to unifying happening
it's really quite complex if you map it
out
now where does this content and inform
stuff come in so let's let's chart that
up
hagel says that all of this here is
actually
the unconditioned universal he says the
result was that that
the result was the unconditioned
universal initially in the negative and
abstract sense
that consciousness negated its one-sided
notions and abstracted them
in other words it gave them up but this
is the result the result has a positive
significance
in it the unity of being for self and
being for another is posited
in other words the absolute antithesis
is posited as a self-identical essence
and he says at first this seems to
concern only the form
of the moments in reciprocal relation so
we can talk about
the form of these
units of these units of these
metaphysical
principles we could say
now each one of them has its own form
right
because i am being for self and so does
this chalk and so does this chalkboard
and so do you
and the content of your being for
yourself is not the same thing
as my content of being for
self so there's there's some content and
some form
in both of these but we can also talk
about the positive unity
as perhaps providing a kind of
form can't we so he says um
here we go being
for self and being for another are the
content itself as well
since the antithesis and its truth can
have no other nature than the one
yielded in the result
the content taken in perception to be
true
belongs in fact only to the form in the
unity of which it is dissolved
this content is likewise universal there
can be no other content which by its
particular constitution
would fail to fall
within
the this unconditioned universality so
the unconditioned universality
is actually itself formed
for the content of everything on this
side
this is content this is content
this this are also in certain ways
content we you know
we realized that this was all of these
are content for the unconditioned
universality
why because it's unconditioned because
it is you might say the form
of any of these sorts of structures so
it doesn't matter what content we put in
at this point it's going to have
it's its connection to the form which is
revealed in the structure
here so he says
a content of this kind would be some
particular way
or other of being for itself and being
in relation to another so here we get to
my being for self and my being for
another is not the same thing as
your being for self and being for
another except i suppose insofar
as we're both human beings and have the
same general structure of consciousness
in which case we're
veering towards this unconditioned
universal aren't we
except in that case it's conditioned by
the concept of humanity
but if we're trying to get to the you
know totally
unconditioned we have to abstract even
away from that
so he says in general to be for itself
and to be in relation to another
constitutes the nature and essence of
the content right
the nature and essence of the content
but
the truth of that content is
it's being unconditionally universal
as we get to the universal
we get closer and closer and closer to
what the truth is
the truth is not something we can simply
take for granted
the truth is something that is hard to
attain
and requires us to to make efforts in
order to
win to recover to take away
so he says um the result is simply
and solely universal so now we're going
to shift over
to this side
but because this unconditioned universal
is an object for
consciousness there emerges in it the
distinction of form
and content and in the shape of content
the moments
look like they did when they first
presented themselves
on one side a universal medium of many
subsistent
matters and on the other side of one
reflected into itself
in which their independence is
extinguished
the former is the dissolution of the
thing's independence
that is the passivity that is a being
for another
the latter is being for self we have to
see how these moments exhibit themselves
in the unconditioned universality which
is their
essence it is clear at the outset that
since they exist only in this
universality
they are no longer separated from one
another at all but are in themselves
essentially self-superseding aspects and
what is posited is
only their transition into one another
you notice that the key difference here
is that
consciousness has now been brought to
bear upon the unconditioned universality
so as we're looking about this this you
know content form distinction we thought
that the unconditioned universality of a
sort of form itself
it turns out that it itself possesses
content and form and
the content side is where hegel is going
to be
focusing on in this section he doesn't
really talk much about the form but
we're going to see that that has a
very important role coming up in the
next very long
section so he says about this content
hey there's things going on in this that
we recognize
from our previous investigations in
these other sections
what are they the one reflected into
itself
right and the also
the universal medium
the universal medium is a a plurality
of matters as he says and
this ends up being being for another and
this ends up being being for self so all
of this is packed into the unconditioned
universal
he says because it's an object of
consciousness all of this
is emerging from that the shape of the
content
the moments look like they did when they
first presented themselves back
in in perception right on one side a
universal medium on the other side of
one reflected into itself
then he says the former is the
dissolution of the thing's independence
we have the thing coming back to us
again
and the latter is it's being for self we
have to see he says
how these moments exhibit themselves
where
in this unconditioned universality so
now we're going to be looking at these
same
matters these same moments
these moments were of
the thing now we're not so concerned
just with the thing which is in effect
the content
we're really interested in the form
of what's happening with unconditioned
universality and how consciousness plays
into that
so he says uh it's clear at the outset
that they they exist only in this
universality they're no longer separated
from one another at all
but they're essentially self-superseding
aspects what is positive
is only their transition into one
another what we have there
is a little bit of foreshadowing about
hegel's treatment of force
which is going to be coming up very soon